huge news on Twitter news that I am I'm
at least
55 surprised by
the Elon Musk Twitter deal is going
through
you know very often I predict the future
I've got my Nostradamus hat I've got my
crystal ball
this I did not predict I'm not entirely
surprised by it but I thought that Elon
Musk was basically
creating a big publicity storm but
ultimately faking it when he was trying
to buy Twitter and that actually may
have been right in the sense that he did
seem to try to get out of the Twitter
deal from the legal perspective it
started to look like he was not going to
be let out of the Twitter deal so he was
just going to be forced by the courts to
buy Twitter anyway or pay huge fines and
so
uh now Elon Musk has said okay I will
buy Twitter for the price that I
initially said I would buy it for and
Twitter has accepted musk's offer
Twitter issued a statement today quote
or yesterday rather we received the
letter from the musk parties which they
have filed with the SEC the intention of
the company is to close the transaction
at 54.20 per share so this is great
weather musk has to buy it now because
he really wants to buy it or whether
it's because he's forced to buy it by
circumstances which I think is probably
more likely either way it's great Elon
Musk running Twitter is going to be a
huge improvement over the lib
oligarchs who control it now who are
putting their thumb not just their thumb
on the scales they're putting their
whole foot on the scales for the libs
when it comes to elections and we've got
one of those coming up
but also when it comes to just the
regular day-to-day of politics they
suppress the conservatives
they amplify the liberals so yeah that's
great
however
this doesn't solve the problem I've been
talking for the past couple days on this
show
about how
the left and the right have
given away our self-government to
private corporations and to more private
interests
and yes those corporations work in
tandem with certain parts of the state
but the corporations are even less
accountable than the state in many cases
why has the left done this well because
they don't have to deal with that sort
of accountability so the the left can
create a bunch of front groups the left
can you you see this with BLM and antifa
the left doesn't want to go in in most
cases and actually send the police to
attack their political opponents they do
it sometimes they use the FBI in this
way they just used it against Donald
Trump they're using against pro-lifers
but usually what the left prefers to do
when it wants to threaten and inflict
political violence on its opponents is
it uses these sort of paramilitary front
groups for the Democratic party that
would be BLM or antifa and they go and
they burn and they rape and they kill
and they pillage and then after months
and months of this they get maybe a
little slap on the wrist they say
naughty naughty don't do that again but
if you do we'll bail you out thanks
thanks for the help antifa thanks for
the help BLM
Kamala Harris is going to go raise money
now so you don't have to sit in the
clinic for too long so that's that's
very often what they do
and it covers it gives them a lot of
cover from accountability well why do
the conservatives do it the
conservatives have have given away
self-government in the name of economic
growth they've said well listen the
government's very inefficient Private
Industry is very efficient and so which
is
Private Industry might be more efficient
than the government but there's
bureaucracy in Private Industry also and
so they say okay we're going to have
public-private Partnerships we're just
going to privatize things entirely and
that's great and that'll be much Freer
it's because of a strain of
libertarianism that really crept into
the conservative movement in the latter
part of the 20th century they say
private always good got public always
bad
and so what does that do well
in some cases it improves things but
when we're talking about Free Speech
when we're talking about the Public
Square if you privatize the Public
Square now all of a sudden you've got a
handful of oligarchs it's not like it's
some thriving free market with lots and
lots of players you're talking about
three or four people right you're
talking about Facebook Twitter Google
that's it right
we got we got
Mark Zuckerberg Jack doors here now now
Elon Musk okay that's an improvement and
Sundar pichai they're controlling the
Public Square
and they're even less accountable than
members of Congress are to us that's no
good it does the Elon Musk purchase of
Twitter doesn't solve the problem it
improves things tactically for a little
while but we need to figure out a way if
we are to restore any semblance of
self-government and the traditional
American way of life
it's not enough to say okay well we've
now we've got our billionaire
corporate CEO running things
good they previously had their
billionaire corporate CEO but now we've
got our billionaire no if we want to
restore any semblance of self-government
we need to say no no the corporations
actually don't get to run the whole
government
they can they have a lot of power but
but we the people in the political
Community we're going to wield some
power too
and you're you're seeing this for so
many years the Republicans just carried
water for corporations frequently
corporations that hated our guts
and now you're you really saw it
starting with Trump you see it
especially with DeSantis you're starting
to see that turn no longer do we hear
well you know if you don't if you don't
like uh half the country being censored
and the president of the United States
being de-platformed then you know build
your own Twitter no I don't think we're
going to do that I think we're going to
take over Twitter perhaps through
private means first like Elon Musk I
hope I think he's certainly more on our
side than the other guys are but then
we're we're going to exert influence on
Twitter as a political community that is
very much our right it's actually Our
obligation if we want to have a
constitutional republic speaking of
pushing these narratives speaking of
everything every single thing becoming
super duper gay
we have got a a trailer for this movie
that my producers insist that I watch
it's called Bros
it's a movie it didn't do very well
apparently at the box office on opening
weekend it's apparently very very gay
they the The Producers want to know if I
should review this movie give an actual
proper review we'll take a look at the
trailer together you tell me if we
should review the movie the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
thank you